bonjour à tous et merci d'être venu si
nombreux ce matin
je suis ravie de voir que que nous
sommes tous réunis autour de la de la
parole et du témoignage de notre grand
témoin aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre
de la santé et de la prévention François
Braun merci de votre présence parmi nous
bonjour merci de nous faire l'honneur
[Applaudissements]
et je vais co animer ce témoignage avec
Monsieur le Député Jean-Pierre
cubertaffond cher Jean-Pierre merci de
ta présence parmi nous
donc Jean-Pierre cubertaffond et député
de la troisième circonscription de
Dordogne depuis 2017
réélu avec succès secrétaire puis
vice-président de la commission de la
Défense nationale et des forces armées
il a été il est rapporteur du budget de
la gendarmerie nationale et auteur d'un
rapport action publique et ruralité à
l'ère de la différenciation qui traite
notamment de la désertification médicale
mais nous y reviendrons voilà donc on va
commencer par monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre donc nous sommes
à l'université de rentrée et qui dit
rentrer dit petit retour sur l'été
écoulé en matière de santé on nous avait
indiqué que qu'il y aurait des
difficultés notamment dans les services
d'urgence cet été est-ce que vous
pourriez nous en parler qu'en est-il
comment on l'était s'est-il écoulé merci
merci d'abord pour votre invitation
merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le ministre madame
la ministre pour cette belle assemblée
et bonjour à tous alors effectivement
entrons dans le vif du sujet tout de
suite donc la question de l'été mon
autre système de santé est en grande
difficulté c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
je pense que le diagnostic maintenant
est partagé par tout le monde il n'y a
pas besoin d'y revenir même si on pourra
avoir quelques particularités locales et
cette grande difficulté s'exprime
essentiellement par les services
d'urgence qui sont la partie émergée de
l'iceberg mais il faut pas croire que si
on résout le problème des services
d'urgence on va résoudre le problème de
santé c'est un petit peu le symptôme de
l'ensemble de la maladie et il faudra
traiter la maladie maintenant le service
d'urgence comme les maternités
d'ailleurs qui ont été en grande
difficulté cet été et qui sont toujours
en grande difficulté c'est un de mes
points d'inquiétude
on soigne le symptôme parce que les nos
concitoyens sont très attachés à leur
service d'urgence pour plein de raisons
et puis c'est un petit peu conique de
cette égalité ou inégalité d'accès
d'accès à la santé alors les services
d'urgence étaient en difficulté le sont
toujours mais vous le savez j'avais été
amené à la demande de la première
ministre et puis de ma prédécesseur
Brigitte bourguignon à faire un travail
avec des collègues gentils généralistes
sur des propositions
c'est la fameuse mission flash alors
qu'on a beaucoup moqué sur le terme mais
maintenant tout le monde utilise ça j'ai
vu donc c'est finalement pas si mal
cette mission qui a permis de sortir 41
idées qui n'étaient pas à des idées
venues de venus d'un bureau mais
vraiment nous sommes allés chercher sur
le terrain et cette cette ce mode de
fonctionnement et celui que je veux
maintenant
impulsé au niveau du ministère
c'est-à-dire aller voir sur le terrain
ce qui se passe ce qui ne va pas ce qui
marche pourquoi ça marche le développer
et l'exporter c'est ce qui s'est passé
avec ces 41 mesures et force est de
constater que c'est plutôt un succès que
l'été s'est passé
sans grande difficulté en tout cas sans
difficulté supplémentaire grâce à la
mobilisation des professionnels c'est
surtout ça qu'il faut le dire et ce qui
est remarquable et on a retrouvé en cela
un petit peu le l'esprit covid c'est la
mobilisation des professionnels de
l'hôpital mais aussi une mobilisation
des professionnels libéraux qui sont
organisés localement de façon très
diverses en prenant des des outils
différents de cette boîte à outils pour
répondre ce qu'on appelle les soins non
programmés c'est-à-dire ces demandes
urgentes alors quels sont les mesures
principales finalement même si je suis
dans l'attente du rapport de l'Igas sur
ces mesures de l'été puisque je m'étais
engagé à dire si les mesures sont
efficaces sont les gardes ce ne sont pas
efficaces on les remet à la poubelle
globalement la régulation médicale qui
en fait le fait de dire aux gens avant
de vous déplacer appelé appelé parce que
les urgences ne sont pas la solution
pour tout si vous avez une angine il
vaut mieux aller voir un médecin
généraliste que d'aller aux urgences si
vous avez un infarctus il vaut mieux que
les urgences viennent vous chercher
plutôt que d'aller voir votre médecin
généraliste donc c'est un peu toute
cette évaluation de la situation
d'urgence où on parle de qualification
de la demande qui est faite par la
régulation médicale ça a fonctionné il y
a une augmentation du nombre d'appels
dans les régulations médicales que ce
soit au SAMU ou que ce soit au service
d'accès aux soins avec des problèmes là
aussi à organiser pour mieux répondre et
une diminution du nombre de passages aux
urgences cet été de l'ordre de 6%. donc
on se rend compte que cette cette
régulation médicale est efficace autre
outil qui de toute façon de toute
évidence est efficace c'est ce qu'on a
mis en place pour les médecins
généralistes c'est-à-dire mobiliser les
médecins généralistes en valorisant
l'acte qu'ils acceptaient de faire sur
la demande de la régulation radical il y
avait quelque chose il y a encore
quelque chose de très compliqué c'est
une partie de l'avenant neuf qu'ils
avaient signé avec la convention
médicale là on a simplifié les choses
ils acceptent de faire un acte à la
demande du SAMU ou du service accès aux
soins ils ont 15 euros de plus ils en
ont pas abusé 4 % seulement mais ça a
permis de décoincer des situations voilà
très rapidement les choses il y a plein
d'autres mesures il y en a 39 autres
mais globalement celle-ci ont bien
marché d'autres moins marché
probablement parce que ils n'ont pas eu
le temps de s'exprimer complètement
c'est le j'appelle le partage de la
pénibilité il est anormal que la
pénibilité liée aux garde de nuit aux
garde de week-end ne repose que sur
l'hôpital public tous doit y participer
à l'échelle d'un territoire j'ai proposé
qu'on puisse justement organiser ce
partage de pénibilité ça assez mal
fonctionné il faut le reconnaître mais
on va on va aller plus loin
oui c'est très intéressant sur le
partage de pénibilité et le
l'articulation entre les soins qui sont
apportés par la médecine de ville et la
médecine enfin hospitalière en réalité
et la part de responsabilité que chacun
peut occuper dans dans la prise en
charge des patients on sait qu'il y a
énormément de
de besoins en fait moi je suis élue dans
le sixième arrondissement de Paris je
m'occupe de la santé j'ai ce
portefeuille là je m'occupe aussi du
handicap et l'alimentation durable et
même dans le sixième arrondissement de
Paris nous sommes à 20% de personnes qui
n'ont pas de médecin traitant
actuellement et donc qui n'ont pas de
facilité d'accès aux soins
voilà que qu'on peut obtenir de son
médecin traitant facilement donc c'est
vrai que qu'il y a cet enjeu mais Paris
est pas et pas la zone la plus la plus
touchée par la désertification médicale
vous le savez bien Jean-Pierre cuillère
à fond
[Musique]
donc ces chiffres sont très alarmants
et donc ces femmes et ses hommes qui
luttent quotidiennement pour pouvoir se
faire soigner c'est une véritable
c'est un véritable handicap et
particulièrement dans les territoires
ruraux
ces phénomènes sont mis à lumière par
trois caractéristiques que je vous
résume très rapidement le temps passé
pour se rendre de pouvoir un
professionnel de santé le deuxième point
c'est les deux les délais d'obtention
pour les rendez-vous et le troisième
point c'est l'accessibilité à des
plateaux médico-techniques je crois que
ce soit les trois points les plus
importants donc ce constat est sans
appel et monsieur le ministre je sais
que vous vous penchez sur ce dossier
mais la situation se dégrade et 30% de
la population
sont dans des zones sous dotées il y a
10 ans et bien les chiffres étaient
moins révélateurs il y avait environ
8% de gens qui n'étaient pas
aujourd'hui on est à plus de
11%. voilà je reviens au délai de
rendez-vous très rapidement chez un
médecin généraliste c'est pas le plus
difficile mais il faut quand même des
fois 24 à 48 heures et souvent quand le
patient arrive que le médecin a pris sa
retraite où est parti et bien les
médecins qui sont avec dans la maison
médicale avec lui leur disent non on ne
peut plus vous prendre on n'a pas de
place donc ça devient très important
chez les dentistes n'en parlons pas
c'est aussi ces multiplié par 20 et
quand aux ophtalmo et bien il faut
parfois six mois pour obtenir un
rendez-vous voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire j'ai pu me rendre compte de cette
situation puisque j'ai fait un rapport
que Mavic commandé le précédent Premier
ministre et c'est vrai que la situation
il y a eu des il y a eu des avancées il
faut le reconnaître les maisons
médicales les maisons médicales
lorsqu'elles sont conçues par des
médecins il ne faut pas que ça soit des
des maisons médicales qui soient
envisagées comme un développement
immobilier par des élus il faut
absolument que les maisons médicales
soient
à l'origine faite par des médecins il y
a eu aussi le numérique clausus il faut
le reconnaître nous sommes les premiers
à l'avoir supprimé mais avant qu'il
agisse il faut environ 10 ans donc ce
n'est pas une solution et le
développement de la télémédecine voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire après
peut-être que on pourra parler des
solutions mais peut-être que vous voulez
déjà intervenir à ce niveau là mais la
situation est grave vous le savez et il
faut qu'on trouve des solutions
rapides immédiate mais on pourra pas
trouver de solution avec le nombre de
médecins parce que le nombre de médecins
étant diminution et et si on a 100
médecins même si on en déplace on en a
toujours 100 donc il faut trouver des
solutions autre que le volume des
médecins
oui mais merci effectivement je partage
bien sûr votre diagnostic toutefois je
pense qu'il faut pas qu'on oublie
certains points de base nous avons un
système de santé exceptionnel je crois
que effectivement on est dans une
logique
où les choses vont mal mais la sécurité
sociale quand on va voir ce qui se passe
à l'étranger et quand même un système
remarquable qui protège les plus faibles
d'entre nous je crois qu'il faut aussi
il faut aussi le rappeler nous avons
aussi un système de santé qui a résisté
plus que bien à cette crise sanitaire
qui est de la résilience qui a su
s'adapter donc j'ai plutôt la tendance à
voir les verres à moitié plein qu'à
moitié vide donc certes la situation est
la situation est difficile il faut pas
se il faut pas se cacher notre système
de santé est en crise mais nous avons un
terreau qui est quand même extrêmement
solide alors
vous parler du nombre de médecins bon
Marianne 28 millions ouais je pense
qu'il pousse un peu mais bon c'est
normal surtout quand c'est en gros titre
comme ça moi ce qui m'intéresse déjà sur
ce sur ce volume ce sont les personnes
les plus fragiles qui n'ont pas de
médecin traitant d'abord je crois qu'il
faut aller marche par marche vouloir
tout résoudre d'un coup par une une
mesure soi-disant miracle et unique ça
n'existe pas je vous rejoins il y a
plein de solutions plein d'outils à
mettre sur la table donc bon
intéressons-nous en tout cas moi je
m'intéresse d'abord à ces personnes les
plus fragiles qui seraient de l'ordre de
600 000 c'est déjà beaucoup trop mais
intéressons-nous d'abord ensuite est-ce
que c'est le nombre de médecins qui est
important ou est-ce que c'est le temps
médical moi je m'intéresse beaucoup plus
à cette notion de temps médical pourquoi
parce que on n'arrête pas de dire que
les jeunes confrères qui arrivent il
travaille moins il voit moins de malade
etc peut-être ils ont ils ont décidé
d'avoir un mode d'exercice qui est
différent de leurs aînés ils ont
certainement raison et nous sommes dans
une société où on doit aussi privilégier
le temps de famille le temps de repos
etc donc c'est très bien il y a une
diminution de ce temps mais d'un autre
côté on leur impose du bureaucratisme je
dis pas de l'administratif mais du
bureaucratisme qui fait qu'il passe
généralisme disent entre 15 et 20 % de
leur temps à remplir des papiers à
l'hôpital je serai plutôt en train de
dire que c'est entre 30 et 50%. donc
déjà redonnons du temps de soin et ça
c'est valable pour tous les
professionnels de santé supprimons ces
ces bureaucratisme
inutile et on a des exemples ma santé
2022 outre les maisons de santé les CPTs
on en parlera amener les assistants
médicaux et la sécurité sociale nous a
montré que les assistants médicaux un
médecin alors actuellement c'est des
groupes qui peuvent les avoir un groupe
de médecins qui a un incident médical ça
permet d'augmenter la clientèle de 10%
simplement en redonnant du temps de soin
par rapport à du temps administratif
donc moi je veux aller dans ce sens je
veux développer les assistants médicaux
essentiellement en zone soudance pour
tous les médecins même le médecin seul
il doit pouvoir avoir ça mais alors là
on ouvre une autre une autre page c'est
la plupart du temps les confrères en
milieu rural en plus n'ont pas les
locaux pour accueillir un assistant
médical en même temps qui consulte ils
ont souvent juste leur salle d'attente
et leur cabinet et c'est là que je
souhaite dans le CNR mais on va en
reparler
mouillé quelque part les élus que vous
êtes en disant par territoire et bien
tout le monde va se mettre autour de la
table tout le monde a une petite pierre
à apporter pour peut-être augmenter la
surface d'un cabinet et dès les médecins
à faire cela pour gagner du temps
médical donc gagner du temps médical
gagner du temps de soin est un élément
gagner du temps médical c'est aussi
travailler sur le partage de compétences
sur les transferts de tâches entre
professionnels de santé un désert
médical c'est pas forcément un désert de
santé et on a bien vu que le transfert
de compétences entre professionnels par
exemple la vaccination que peut faire
les infirmiers les pharmaciens
maintenant permet là aussi de redonner
du temps médical donc voilà déjà deux
outils deux axes de réflexion qui sont
intéressants je peux vous répondre parce
que j'ai été maire d'une commune et j'ai
facilité la création d'une maison
médicale et aujourd'hui on a une jeune
femme médecin 40 ans et très jeune et
elle a pris une assistante médicale elle
a pris une assistante médicale qui
s'occupe de préparer les dossiers qui
s'occupent des règlements qui s'occupent
de prendre des rendez-vous et elle avait
une clientèle d'environ mille patients
elle est passée à 1250 patients parce
que justement il y avait l'assistante
médicale le sans travailler plus on
respectant les horaires de travail quel
s'était fixée alors on peut vous dire
oui mais l'assistant médical il y a un
coût
et bien j'ai rencontré récemment
monsieur fantôme et qui m'a dit qu'il
était prêt à financer des postes par la
par la partie assurance maladie et que
il faut absolument développer des
assistants médicaux parce que on peut
gagner déjà sur une commune de 1500
habitants
ce médecin généraliste a gagné 250
patients parce que justement elle s'est
organisée oui nous avons aussi ce qui a
été mis en place dans le quinquennat
précédent qui sont les ce qu'on appelle
les infirmières azalées qui sont ces
infirmières un peu de santé publique qui
assure le suivi des patients chroniques
qui rappellent les gens qui évitent des
consultations itératives on voit qu'on
commence à avoir un paysage des outils
qui sont pas assez connus mais qui vont
nous permettre parce que je le dis je le
dis tout le temps prétendre qu'on va
avoir 10
000 médecins de plus demain et 150 000
infirmières c'est mentir aux Français
c'est pas possible on les aura pas déjà
on voit cette année on a du mal à
recruter dans les écoles et en plus pour
les former il faudra entre 5 et 10 ans
donc utilisons les troupes qui sont sur
le terrain donnons-leur de l'amplitude
horaire pour faire du soin ça va déjà
nous permettre de baisser un peu cette
pression mais si vous avez tout à fait
raison aujourd'hui on ne peut pas il ne
faut plus mentir aux élus en leur disant
qu'on va leur procurer des médecins il y
en a pas assez donc il faut gagner et le
temps médical fait partie de d'une
solution il y a une autre solution que
je voulais vous proposer moi j'ai un
médecin qui a pris sa retraite qui est
en pleine forme et qui veut continuer à
travailler vous savez pourquoi ils ne le
font pas ils ne le font pas parce que
leur cotisations l'URSSAF et caisse de
retraite est trop élevé donc aujourd'hui
si vous facilitiez le rapport emploi
salarié pas salarié emploi
retraite on peut gagner moi j'ai compté
sur le département de la Dordogne si les
médecins il faut qu'il faut les prendre
des petites arêtes
c'est à dire des médecins à retraités
actifs moi je pouvais gagner 30 à 40
mètres ça sur un département donc il
faudrait absolument modifier la loi je
sais pas de quelle façon un amendement
mais il faudrait que le médecin n'est
plus les charges de sa caisse de
retraite et l'URSSAF sinon il arrête de
travailler parce que il n'a pas
suffisamment de revenu pour payer ses
charges et ça les médecins retraités
c'est une solution qui peut être mise en
place très vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a la vision médicale mais je pense
que et le gouvernement va travailler
dessus il y a la vision plus globale
c'est-à-dire que ce travail se travaille
pour les retraités actifs concernent
certes les médecins mais concerner aussi
d'autres professions et il y a des
réflexions à avoir autour de deux autres
propositions à vous faire et après je
redonnerai la parole et j'ai la médecine
foraine alors sachant qu'un peu le terme
mais ce sont les médecins il y a eu une
expérience qui a été faite le médecin
une fois par semaine va dans un village
important où il n'y a plus de médecins
c'est lui qui se déplace et la mairie ou
la communauté de communes mais à sa
disposition une une salle pour recevoir
les patients et la deuxième proposition
c'est c'est à l'inverse c'est le
médecin est dans un cabinet médical et
établit un planning et la communauté de
communes et là on pourrait peut-être
faire une expérimentation dans une ou
deux communautés de communes la
Communauté de Communes fournit une
voiture électrique
on demande à des étudiants ont fait des
plannings on demande à des étudiants de
véhiculer des gens qui ne peuvent pas se
déplacer moi je suis sensibilisé par le
milieu rural puisque je suis un rural et
j'ai des gens qui peuvent pas se
déplacer il y a des problèmes de
mobilité si on mettait leur disposition
une petite voiture électrique je suis
sûr qu'il y a des sociétés aujourd'hui
qui font des hyper bénéfices et qui
pourraient nous aider à mettre sur place
ces voitures les étudiants pourraient
amener des gens dans le cabinet médical
en organisant voilà c'est les deux
propositions que je vous fais et on
pourrait faire une expérimentation par
exemple en dehors
alors
je vous suis je vous suis sur ce chemin
j'ai même vous apporter une troisième
solution
alors la médecine foraine c'est le
Conseil de l'Ordre qui a été disait
cette médecine foraine c'est fini
maintenant il y a pas de problème enfin
ce principe de de consultation quand on
est dans une zone bien notée de pouvoir
un jour par semaine aller faire une
consultation dans une zone sous de tes
voisines bien sûr il faut le il faut
l'appuyer il faut l'appuyer d'autant
plus que ces médecins dans les zones
vient de thé ont souvent des étudiants
en médecine donc il resterait avec leur
cabinet de groupe et eux se
déplaceraient en fondament plein de
modalités à mettre en place le parallèle
un petit peu sur une autre solution qui
est complémentaire c'est le
développement de la télémédecine
accompagnée ce qu'on a mis en place cet
été ce qui marche très bien c'était les
médecines avec une infirmière qui a la
possibilité d'aller faire une évaluation
de contacter un médecin à distance par
télémédecine ça marche aussi pour les
spécialistes et qui permet là aussi de
gagner du temps mais pour votre voiture
électrique je vais aller plus loin parce
que la voiture électrique il va falloir
faudrait deux non mais vous n'avez je
vais vous expliquer que vous n'avez même
pas besoin de l'acheter parce que j'ai
discuté avec un
non non je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
j'ai discuté avec un élu rural mais je
suis sûr que c'est pareil chez vous je
suis sûr que vous avez une équipe de
foot dans votre commune
votre équipe de foot elle fait des
matchs le dimanche
elle a un petit bus et ben voilà et ben
quand c'est pas le dimanche vous prenez
un employé municipal pourquoi pas avec
le petit bus qui prend les personnes
âgées et qui s'organise avec les
médecins j'étais hier soir au Congrès
enfin aux journées de rentrée aussi d'un
syndicat de médecin généraliste à SMS
mais ils m'ont dit nous on est prêt il y
a aucun problème on est prêt à bloquer
un après-midi par semaine de nos
consultations pour cette médecine de
personnes qui viendraient des villages
alentours par le minibus du foot pour
les amener en consultation j'ai pas
pensé parce que j'ai pas d'équipe de
foot c'est une équipe de rugby donc je
n'y avais pas pensé effectivement
j'aurais dû utiliser ça parce que bon
vous le savez je suis plus vers le
ballon ovale que vers la balle ronde
mais bon
ses premiers éléments il y a quelque
chose qui a été pointé et je voudrais en
profiter pour faire un petit clin d'œil
à notre président qui est présent ce
matin c'est le volet santé du Conseil
national de la refondation cher
président
donc il va y avoir un volet un volet
santé est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un mot est-ce que vous avez des
éléments à porter sur sur ce volet santé
sachant qu'ensuite on gardera du temps
pour les questions qui commencent à
arriver n'hésitez pas à envoyer des SMS
et puis un petit temps également pour
parler de prévention parce que voilà un
ministère de la de la santé et de la
prévention ça donne l'accent quand même
sur sur ce sujet
oui merci le temps file donc je vais
essayer d'être bref sur ce CNR versant
santé alors on n'a pas fait exprès ça
fait CNRS ça parle beaucoup en français
mais bon en tout cas c'est comme ça donc
ce CNR santé je vais lancer le 3 octobre
les 3 octobre depuis pas depuis mon
bureau depuis Le Mans pourquoi parce que
je veux marquer que ça concerne les
territoires que ça concerne la province
d'abord et puis le Mans est dans une
situation compliquée en termes médicales
comme un petit peu tout toute cette
région donc ce CNR santé il va se
décliner sous plusieurs formes une
première forme la plus importante qui
est territoriale
cette forme territoriale ça va être des
débats à l'échelle de des territoires à
l'échelle que vous voudrez organiser
vous les élus ça peut être la commune
l'intercommunalité ça peut être le
département la région c'est peut-être un
peu grand mais en tout cas à l'échelle
que vous voudrez ces débats
j'impose une chose c'est qu'il enfin
j'ai un pose
j'insiste fortement à une chose c'est
qu'il y a systématiquement élu
professionnel de santé citoyen
autre point ce ne sont pas des débats
pour faire des diagnostics de territoire
ce sont des débats pour poser les
problèmes et voir quelles solutions on
peut mettre dessus
on est dans l'action donc les solutions
existent ou elles existent pas et si on
les invente on les invente on les teste
si ça marche on les garde c'est ça le
principe
dans ces débats c'est comme au patinage
artistique on est très proche du rugby
il y a des figures imposées des figures
libres les figures imposées on traite
des médecins traitant pour les plus
fragiles on traite de la permanence des
soins l'attractivité des métiers de
santé sur le territoire et comment
intégrer la prévention dans le
dispositif ça c'est un petit peu les
figures imposées les figures libres et
bien c'est la problématique spécifique
de telle ou tel territoire j'ai un élu
d'Alsace qui m'a dit moi je veux parler
de transfrontalier parce que je
travaille avec l'Allemagne à côté pas de
problème on parle de transfrontalier on
met des solutions ça ça démarre le 3
octobre ça va sèche le alors ça va être
avec le soutien
organisationnel des préfectures et des
sous-préfectures et le soutien technique
des ARS nous sommes en train de former
un peu plus de 300 personnes dans les
ARS avec un petit kit pour pouvoir mener
les débats les différentes questions etc
ça en démarre le 3 octobre il y a
jusqu'à la fin d'année on va faire des
montées redescentes permanentes sur les
idées moi je veux que ce soit vivant ça
va remonter on va tester on va vérifier
au niveau du ministère si ça correspond
au cadre réglementaire si besoin on
adapte le cadre réglementaire bref des
va-et-vient en permanence parallèlement
à cette organisation une interrogation
numérique de tous les Français de tous
notre citoyen sur leur vécu du système
de santé là aussi on veut pas être dans
la dolérance perpétuelle c'est vraiment
ce qu'ils ont vécu les difficultés voir
les belles solutions qu'ils ont vu
troisième partie de ce CNR vous voyez il
est très ambitieux une partie CNR plus
nationale parce qu'il y a des sujets
qui n'ont aucune plus-value à être
traité au niveau territorial par exemple
la quatrième année de médecine générale
ce des
comment on organise ça n'a pas de sens
de traiter au niveau territorial
simplification administrative de la même
façon ça c'est CNR format national alors
pourquoi CNR ne tourneur le président
parce que on reste dans cette logique
citoyen soignant élu dans ses réflexions
et puis parallèlement à cela je vais
lancer des réflexions beaucoup plus
larges sur le système de santé alors
dans un mode un peu plus traditionnel on
est hors CNR mais le financement du
système de santé la gouvernance du
système de santé voilà des questions
qu'il faut qu'on se pose maintenant
parce que vous le savez et je le dis
tout le temps notre système de santé qui
a été construit sur l'offre de soins
n'est plus du tout adaptée aux besoins
actuels c'est d'ailleurs le cas des
mêmes systèmes de santé au niveau
européen il faut qu'on retourne un peu
la table qu'on la remettre dans le bon
sens et le bon sens c'est un système de
santé qui est centré sur la réponse aux
besoins de santé de nos concitoyens et
non pas simplement offrir mettre une
offre de soins sur le territoire voilà
très rapidement de s'énerve vous voyez
c'est très ambitieux c'est ambitieux
parce que le Président de la République
m'a dit c'est facile il y a 1200 bassins
de vie donc il faut faire 1200 débats je
pense que déjà si on en fait un petit
peu moins c'est bien mais je veux que la
parole soit donnée au territoire soit
donné aux soignants aux soignés aux élus
pour faire remonter les bonnes idées
même sont sur les territoires les
solutions aussi
merci Monsieur ministre
[Applaudissements]
nous commençons à recevoir des
témoignages par SMS et notamment un
témoignage d'une personne qui indique
qu'elle vit dans une zone très habité et
il n'y a actuellement plus de
dermatologues dans dans sa zone
géographique et l'impression qu'elle a
et que personne ne souhaite plus devenir
médecin ou spécialiste et elle
s'interroge sur sur les solutions à
apporter à tout ça
fait écho est-ce que vous indiquez sur
l'adéquation entre l'offre de soins et
les besoins sur sur le terrain
bel exemple parce que ça marche en
télémédecine de façon superbe avec des
dermatoscopes
voilà ophtalmo dentiste on a des
solutions aussi je vais pas vous faire
croire qu'on a des solutions surtout
mais il faut prendre les outils qui
existent les ophtalmos ils ont les
orthoptistes qui leur permet de faire
pas mal de choses d'ailleurs les
ophtalmos sont une spécialité médicale
qui a travaillé sur l'avenir de sa
profession à 20 ans 30 ans et qui
commence à dire ouais on va peut-être
arrêter de faire des ophtalmos tellement
on a ce transfert de compétences et puis
les chirurgiens dentistes je les ai
rencontrés là ils poussent mais c'était
dans le programme du président de la
République pour les assistants dentaires
de niveau 2 qui vont là aussi pour faire
dans le cadre de transfert de
compétences et de tâches un certain
nombre de la détartrage des soins
simples qui permettra au dentiste de se
concentrer sur sa véritable plus-value
dans les soins de la bouche
alors vous avez indiqué qu'il y aurait
donc trois
types de d'intervenants donc pour pour
le CNR les élus les patients en réalité
les citoyens et les médecins évidemment
en tout cas les professionnels de santé
les soignants donc nous nous venons dans
mon arrondissement de créer une CPTs et
on en arrive au thème de la prévention
puisque le quelque chose qui se retrouve
pardon pour pour l'acronyme CPTs c'est
une communauté professionnelle
territoriale de santé ça consiste pour
les
professionnels de santé ou tous les
métiers du soin et pour les personnes de
même les paramédicaux de se constituer
en communauté pour pouvoir travailler
ensemble sur les questions la question
primordiale dans toutes les CPCs de
France c'est l'accès aux soins comment
trouver des médecins et des soins
adaptés pour chaque personne du
territoire
des c'est des communautés qui sont
locales qui sont territorialisées mais
de façon très locale nous c'est à
l'échelle de l'arrondissement et
l'autre volet je crois en tout cas chez
nous c'est le choix que nous avons fait
c'est de de parler de prévention et de
d'avoir des objectifs en matière de
prévention
récemment donc moi je suis donc à Paris
et comme élu mais je suis en Moselle
temporairement pour pour quelques temps
c'est une région une zone que vous
connaissez bien
et vous étiez présents assez récemment
parce que vous avez inauguré une maison
sport santé et ce que vous pouvez nous
en parler est-ce que c'est l'un des axes
qui pourraient être mis en avant pour la
prévention
je rebondis vite sur la CPTs CPTs il
faut en avoir alors partout où j'ai vu
des choses qui fonctionnaient il y a une
CPTs mais malheureusement par tout il y
a une CPTs il y a pas des choses qui
fonctionnent donc il y a un petit
équilibre à trouver mais en tout cas
c'est un très bel outil alors sport
santé oui sport santé pourquoi nous
sommes en retard nous sommes un pays à
l'âge de pierre de la prévention
malheureusement donc il faut qu'on il
faut qu'on amène nos concitoyens vers
des actes de prévention le problème de
la prévention je suis désolé de le dire
ici c'est pas politiquement bankable
parce que les actions de prévention
qu'on fait elles sont efficaces dans 10
ans dans 15 ans dans 20 ans donc il faut
déjà et je remercie le président de la
République d'avoir bien mis le ministère
de la Santé et de attention ça veut dire
qu'il y a une volonté politique forte
d'ailleurs on le voit sur la mise en
place des consultations aux achetés de
la vie on pourra arriver si vous voulez
mais pour revenir sur sport et santé
comment comment j'en suis arrivé là mais
pas tout seul je vous rassure
au 1er janvier on est tous pareils on
veut faire du sport on veut arrêter de
fumer on veut pas boire plus d'un verre
de vin par jour etc ça c'est bon et le 2
janvier on a tous arrêté bon allez
peut-être le 4
je pense que nous avons une occasion
dans les années qui viennent alors on
parle beaucoup des Jeux Olympiques oui
moi je suis désolé je parle aussi de la
Coupe du monde de rugby c'est l'année
prochaine donc ça vient plus vite donc
nous avons une occasion superbe la
France va se transformer en un grand
terrain de sport tout le monde va
vouloir faire du sport et le sport dans
la prévention est quelque chose de très
intéressant parce que on se sent mieux
tout de suite commencer à marcher à
monter les escaliers plutôt prendre
l'ascenseur au bout d'un mois vous vous
sentez mieux et je trouve que c'est ça
l'idée de sport et santé et je partage
cela avec Amélie ou desa Castéra avec
qui j'étais d'ailleurs en Moselle c'est
faisons de la prévention quelque chose
de ludique et quelque chose qui se voit
tout de suite donc utilisons le sport
pleinement et c'était déjà le cas dans
ma santé 2022 mais on va démultiplier ça
utilisons le sport 1 parce que ça va
être un réel gain vous savez il y a
quatre cancers sur 10 qui sont liés à
nos mauvaises habitudes alimentaires ou
de vie huit maladies cardiovasculaires
sur 10 le traitement de l'hypertension
artérielle c'est pour la sécurité
sociale près d'un milliard et demi par
an en traitement on ne remboursement on
pourrait diminuer de 60% simplement en
faisant de l'exercice pas seulement du
sport mais de l'exercice donc on voit
bien qu'on a des enjeux qui sont majeurs
là-dessus profitons de ce grand élan sur
le sport vous ramener la prévention par
ce côté plus ludique puis derrière je
vous cache pas que j'ai d'autres
prétentions sur la prévention il y en a
une que j'affiche souvent la vaccination
contre le papillomavirus pour les jeunes
garçons les jeunes filles avant l'âge
par des relations sexuelles c'est la
disparition du cancer du col de l'utérus
les Australiens sont en train de nous le
montrer c'est totalement aberrant qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire ce pas
supplémentaire on n'a pas assez de
jeunes filles vaccinées et très très peu
de garçons allons-y simplement parler de
vaccins aux Français aujourd'hui c'est
un peu compliqué donc on va on va passer
par le sport amener ça à essayer de
faire de notre société une société
tournée vers la prévention
merci monsieur le ministre
il y a deux questions qui nous ont été
posées mais j'ai très très vite c'est
les
maîtres de stage il y a pas assez de
mettre de stage est-ce qu'il faudrait
pas prendre une mesure ou inciter les
médecins à ce qui doit mettre du stage
et on n'a pas abordé le rôle du
pharmacien le pharmacien peut peut-être
aussi délivrer des ordonnances
renouveler des livrets et renouveler ou
aussi prescrire des antalgiques très
connues qui éviteraient que le médecin
soit accaparé par ces choses-là oui bien
sûr alors les maîtres de stage oui ça
c'est le numerus clausus a laissé place
au numerus à Perthus mais qui laisse aux
facultés la possibilité de prendre plein
d'étudiants à condition d'avoir des
enseignants donc là aussi même au niveau
universitaire d'ailleurs il faut
redonner envie aux médecins d'être
universitaire des enseignants là aussi
il y a un gros boulot à faire sur la sur
la retraite des Hospitaliers on a pas
mal de choses les maîtres de stage oui
alors après les maîtres de stage il faut
aussi qu'on revienne à des choses
raisonnables on demande aujourd'hui à
médecin généraliste pour être maître
l'avantage des choses qui de ma part
semblent un petit peu démesuré il faut
qu'il sache encadrer les étudiants bien
sûr mais faut pas non plus en demander
trop si on veut en avoir plus ça c'est
un milieu rural si le médecin reçoit des
maîtres des étudiants ça peut lui donner
envie de revenir et de se familiariser
avec le milieu rural de ne pas avoir
peur du milieu on n'a pas eu là j'ai pas
le temps parce que je vous avais dit
j'étais bavard hein mais il y a des
mesures immédiates pour le désert
médicaux il y a des mesures à moyen
terme qui sont justement ces étudiants
ces stagiaires il y a des mesures à long
terme qui sait ce que j'appelle des
parcours d'excellence ça marche à les
repérer les jeunes dans les lycées dès
la première des la terminale les
accompagner sur leurs études enfin on a
plein de choses à faire on va on va
cranter un petit peu tout ça vous parlez
des pharmaciens oui bien sûr on a vu
avec la vaccination n'aurait jamais
réussi ces chiffres de vaccination covid
sans les pharmaciens vous voyez avec la
dispensation là de la pilule du
lendemain pour toutes les femmes par le
pharmacien sans ordonnance gratuitement
et puis il y a des expérimentation
il y a des expérimentations qui sont
très efficaces sur la prescription
d'antibiotiques dans des pathologies
urinaires bénignes la prescription
d'antalgique c'est déjà libre très
probablement aussi d'antibiotiques
lorsqu'on fait des tests sur des angines
vous savez un pharmacien le fait très
bien aussi voir si c'est une angine à
streptocoopa faut-il donner des
antibiotiques enfin il y a plein de
pistes et là j'ai confié ça aux ordres
j'ai demandé au début du mois avec une
réponse pour la fin du mois alors j'ai
un peu un peu secoué nos vieilles
institutions ordinales les ordres de
santé sont réunies dans un groupe et
doivent me faire avant la fin du mois
des propositions sur ces transferts de
compétences c'est eux qui ont la
responsabilité du cadre de l'exercice
professionnel c'est à eux de donner des
ouvertures même le kiné pourquoi faut-il
qu'il y ait une prescription du médecin
généraliste pour aller voir un kiné
le kiné le traumatisme il y a pas mal de
choses après il y a un impératif c'est
garantir la qualité et la sécurité des
soins ça c'est impératif mais je pense
que les ordres vont me faire des
propositions intéressantes quand ils
auront fini de s'échapper là en ce
moment ça va aller moi j'ai bien noté
donc que vous alliez me fournir un bus
pour la Dordogne c'est ça j'ai bien
compris non j'ai bien noté que je
viendrai voir jouer votre équipe de
rugby si elle joue bien peut-être qu'on
fera quelque chose
alors je vous propose que que nous
prenions une dernière question
elle nous est posée de la façon suivante
comment identifier des modalités pour
permettre aux jeunes médecins payés par
l'État d'exercer au moins deux ans en
zone rurale
pourrait-on envisager un engagement
décennale
c'est gentil de me poser cette question
j'adore alors
non mais là aussi il faut remettre les
choses les choses à leur place j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec une dame sur
France Inter qui me disait oui c'est une
honte enfin ce qu'on entend d'habitude
les profs eux ils ont pas le choix etc
etc les médecins non plus
si vous êtes médecin vous décidez de
rentrer dans le service public
hospitalier comme un prof qui rentre
dans l'éducation nationale vous n'avez
pas le choix de l'endroit où vous
installez vous installez là où il y a un
poste
donc c'est pareil si vous êtes magistrat
effectivement une fille qui est
magistrate elle a pas le choix de son
poste elle rentre dans le grand service
public et la magistrature elle va où il
y a de la place par contre le prof qui
décide d'aller dans du privé
il va où il veut
le médecin libéral il va où il veut
l'avocat il va il veut donc c'est si
vous voulez l'argument de dire on le
fait pour les autres on le fait pas pour
les docteurs c'est une honte il ne tient
pas ensuite il y a de dire oui mais ils
sont payés par la Sécurité Sociale oui
mais je redis ce que je disais tout à
l'heure louons la sécurité sociale qui
nous permet de soigner tout le monde
n'inversant pas les choses et puis après
il y a tous les arguments sur les études
en plus ça c'est je dirais de côté un
peu un peu philosophique mais sur le
terrain ça ne fonctionne pas c'est pour
ça que je dis qu'il faut pas le faire
pourquoi ça fonctionne pas dans le
meilleur des cas vous avez ce que
j'appellerais des mercenaires et on
commence à en voir avec les aides à
l'installation des médecins j'ai en tête
un couple là qui a défrayé un peu la
chronique au début de l'été il
s'installe dans un coin il y a l'aide à
l'installation il prend tout trois ans
au bout de trois ans il se barrent il va
ailleurs dans un autre endroit il
reprend tout etc moi je veux pas des
mercenaires je veux des médecins
traitants qui suivent des familles ça
c'est encore le meilleur des dans le
pire des cas et je discutais hier avec
des jeunes étudiants et des jeunes
médecins généralistes ils me disent
quand ils me disent bah déjà si on nous
impose l'installation 1 on va plus
choisir médecine générale
7% de postes vacance je rentre pas dans
les détails donc on aura moins de
généralistes donc déjà on va être
contre-productif par rapport à ce qu'on
veut et en plus ils disent et ben si on
nous force à nous installer c'est
l'histoire de conventionnement des
conventionnements ben nous on prendra un
boulot salarié il y en a de plus en plus
qui prennent des boules salariés avec
des grosses boîtes qui mettent en place
des maisons de santé comme par hasard
c'est pas dans la campagne c'est en
ville
déjà de médecins beaucoup d'aller vers
le salariat donc attention que le remède
soit pas pire que le mal mais c'est ça
que je dis je vais être très prudent là
dessus et je me permets d'alerter les
parlementaires que vous êtes sur des
fausses bonnes idées qui feraient croire
que une seule idée comme ça va tout
régler ça va aggraver les choses
merci de votre réponse honnête et
franche
je vous propose qu'on qu'on conclut
ce grand témoignage
est-ce que est-ce que je vous souhaitez
ajouter quelque chose
oui monsieur
alors la question qui est posée que je
que je transmets c'est la question de la
santé mentale effectivement c'est un pan
de la santé que qu'on a un peu laissé de
côté mais qui est bien présent dans nos
esprits à tous moi je dois dire que
c'est quelque chose de très important
voilà et la question de la psychiatrie
et de la place de la psychiatrie dans la
médecine peut-être qu'on peut conclure
là dessus la santé mentale est dévastée
enfin je crois que là aussi on va pas on
va pas se cacher on a des énormes
difficultés mais parce qu'on n'a pas les
professionnels donc moi j'ai plusieurs
enjeux j'ai comment
réenchanter si je peux dire ces métiers
de la santé mentale là aussi les
transferts de tâches entre
professionnels les transferts de
compétences avec des infirmiers en
pratique avancées vont nous permettre de
cranter un petit peu les choses mais je
suis extrêmement inquiet quand je vois
les résultats vous les avez vu du
l'observatoire national du suicide qui
montre une explosion des suicides chez
les jeunes filles de 10 à 14 ans et que
nous sommes pas capables d'appréhender
aujourd'hui donc je pour reboucler à ce
que je disais au début on a beaucoup
parlé des urgences cet été mais moi
j'avais trois préoccupations majeures
que j'ai toujours les urgences les
maternités et la psychiatrie qui sont
les secteurs que je suis au plus près
oui
oui alors effectivement la question des
de la santé mentale est très présente je
crois que vous en avez parfaitement
conscience et que vous avez identifié ce
problème comme l'une de vos
préoccupations principales
je voulais vous remercier vraiment
d'être venu ici nous vous retrouvez à
Guidel dans ce cadre que vous avez
découvert cette année on espère vous
retrouver régulièrement parmi nous tous
les ans c'est que merci merci encore de
votre invitation et vous l'avez compris
j'applique et je continue à appliquer ce
que nous a dit la première ministre
c'est écoute action résultats je suis
complètement dans cette logique et je
suis et je reste à votre écoute
merci